consider this we are conscious of both
more and less than affects our nervous
system let me give you an example I look
at a tomato it's sitting there in the
counter in front of me it's red and
bulgy and 3-dimensional and I
experienced all that I experienced all
that visually I have a sense even
visually of the back of the tomato not
that I can see the back of the tomato
it's out of view and yet it's part of my
experience of the tomato that it has a
back its present in that sense to me but
note it doesn't strike my retina it's
present it informs its structures my
visual experience without actually being
an element that stimulates my nervous
system or consider I look at writing on
a text or better example as I walk into
a room and there's graffiti on the wall
and imagine it's graffiti that I find
really offensive I walk in I look at it
my I flush my heart starts to race I'm
outraged I'm taking her back of course
if I didn't know the language in which
it was written I could have had exactly
the same retinal events and the same
events in my in my early visual system
without any corresponding reaction so so
this interesting puzzle much more shows
up for us then just what projects into
our nervous system in fact however
paradoxical it sounds if we think of
what is visible as just what projects to
the eyes we see much more than is
visible and moreover just because
something does enter our eyes provide a
stimulus to the nervous system that
doesn't mean we experience it
psychologists have shown this in the
laboratory with experiments that would
have been called change blindness you
can be looking at something and as
you're looking at it it's changing and
under quite normal conditions people
will to a surprisingly large degree fail
to be able to describe or notice that it
changes occurred it's a little bit like
if I have a plate of french fries
and you say to me hey what's that over
there behind your shoulder and I go like
this and you take one of my fries and
when I turn around I probably won't
notice that anything is missing I don't
I didn't have that kind of a detailed
internal representation of the plate
such that I can compare how the plate
looked before I turned away and how it
looked when I turned back and notice a
discrepancy but that's how our
experience is in general we find
ourselves in placed in an environment
the world is there and we don't need a
detailed internal representation because
we can move our heads flick our eyes
redirect our interest and get the
information we need as we need it our
ability to experience more than is in
some sense there and also less than is
in some sense there I think in a very
strong way point us to the fact that
what shows up for us is not so much a
matter of what is happening inside of us
but how we are achieving or failing to
achieve access to what's going on around
us